Is there a chance Dick Grayson could soon be
making his way to the world of "The Batman"?
What hint did the movie drop
that implied he could? Keep
watching to find out about this comics Easter egg.
Director Matt Reeves' "The Batman" delivers
a brand new version of the Caped Crusader
to the big screen. Sure, DC fans are incredibly
familiar with Bruce Wayne's origin after seeing
it several times in animation and live-action,
but this is a much darker film that takes a
precise look at the tortured vigilante a
couple years into his crimefighting career.
The film has already been a huge hit
with critics. Daily Star's Andy Lea
calls it a "gritty, pacy and
achingly stylish adventure,"
while The Digital Fix's Tom Percival
says it's "surprisingly hopeful."
It's fair to say that this new take on Gotham City
does feel grimier than previous iterations of the
Bat's home turf. It's stylistically similar
to the world of David Fincher's "Seven," with
hints of "Zodiac" in there for good measure.
This largely stems from Paul Dano's haunting
depiction of the Riddler as a terrifying serial
killer who takes aim at the corrupt Gotham elite.
Thankfully, Robert Pattinson's Bruce isn't alone
in his mission to serve justice on city streets;
he's also joined by antihero
Catwoman, played by Zoe Kravitz,
and police Lieutenant James
Gordon, played by Jeffrey Wright.
The film isn't crammed with Easter eggs like other
comic book movies that dominate the box office,
but there are a few carefully placed references to
classic DC characters. The plot itself takes cues
from classic Batman storylines such as "Year
One," "The Long Halloween," and "Zero Year,"
but there's also a surprising nod to one of the
most famous members of the Bat-Family: Nightwing.
By the end of "The Batman," Catwoman, a.k.a.
Selina Kyle, decides that it's time for her to
leave Gotham for a while. It's an understandable
move, because part of her arc revolves around
finding who killed her best friend Annika,
and why. To make matters worse, Selina is
forced to confront the fact that she's the
illegitimate daughter of mobster Carmine Falcone.
He abandoned Selina's mother after their
brief fling, and she was forced to grow up
in poverty as a result. Falcone, meanwhile,
only grew more powerful. So after she helps
Batman stop the Riddler's plan, she tells
the Dark Knight she might head to Bludhaven.
That's a loaded reference for comics readers.
Bludhaven is a city not too far from Gotham.
It's also where Dick Grayson, who
became Nightwing after being Robin,
moves in the comics when he starts to
forge his own identity away from Batman.
"Pranks, jokes and tomfoolery have no place here.
And my identity must reflect that. From
this day forward, call me Nightwing."
As he soon finds out, Bludhaven
is an incredibly violent place,
and there aren't any superheroes operating
there because of how ruthless the villains are.
Nightwing is the one who makes a stand when
Bruce asks him to investigate a string of
deaths in 1996's "Nightwing" issue #1.
It's not enough for Dick to just patrol
the streets at night, though, as he
needs reliable intelligence to take
down gangsters like Blockbuster. He even
ends up becoming a police officer by day.
While it's entirely possible that Reeves and
his co-writer Peter Craig will introduce Dick
Grayson further down the line, the Bludhaven
reference probably isn't a hint that Nightwing
will show up in "The Batman 2." Even if they
introduce Grayson in the sequel, he'll probably
start off as Robin to explore that dynamic with
Batman, rather than stepping into his Nightwing
persona straight away. Name-dropping Bludhaven
is more likely just a bit of worldbuilding.
However, that's not to say Nightwing won't
make the leap to the big screen eventually.
Warner Bros. picked "The Tomorrow War" director
Chris McKay to helm a solo movie for
the hero in the DC Extended Universe.
When speaking to Den of Geek back in 2021, McKay
said he still wants to work on the project:
"I hope that we get a chance to go out and make
that Dick Grayson and Nightwing film. [...] That
particular part of Robin, growing from
being under Batman to becoming Nightwing,
and Bludhaven and all that stuff ...
It's a really personal story to me."
For Nightwing fans desperate
to see the hero in live action,
at least HBO Max's "Titans" will scratch
that itch. Brenton Thwaites plays a version
of the hero that's become a real fan
favorite, and it's not hard to see why.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.